first of all let me just say you have
lit up the internet with that red dress
and people are talking about it please
tell us about that look
oh my goodness thank you yes it's
custom couture by alberta ferretti and
we start working on it maybe about a
week and a couple of days ago
uh my stylist jennifer uh she just had
this vision in her head
and and they they went at it i mean and
i just wait until today to put it on you
know
so it was great i love you know red is
one of my
it's just such a powerful color and it's
you know so the strength and power but
yet
grace and femininity you know i love
that
that beautiful bow one of the headlines
i read said you were introducing red to
the oscars once again
and it worked well what is it like
being there what is the scene like what
has it been like being there all night
long
you know what the venue is beautiful as
you know we're here at union station
looks nothing like a union station from
any train station that you might be used
to
it's really quite a beautiful vibe
it's very relaxed and chill you know you
know
you know what we're used to with the
oscars it's craziest
everyone's crammed and packed in the
excitement and all of that
it's just as exciting um to see your
friends and your colleagues and
and and the folks whose work you you've
seen throughout the
you know you know throughout the year um
so it's still just as exciting but you
actually get to have
a little conversation with them that
goes on
for a minute at least when they don't
tell you
put that mask on
they were after you weren't there like
put that mask on
yeah be compliant you introduced the
memorium
and the chadwick was in that did it make
it
different because you had such a
connection you know what it
certainly it certainly infused it
even more so for me that that portion
of the awards is always so so poignant
and so touching um because we've been
inspired by
so many of those artists um
you know gone gone on made their
transition
but of course you know this being a big
year where of course a great love and a
great artist a great
you know a great man just made his
transition and the world just
warned him and loved himself
along with so many others he expect
cicely tyson was of course a mentor of
mine
and uh and also throughout their
individuals that i've worked
with you know any of my career
went through but um but to see chadwick
it was as if there were even more so
you know of a wake for me to speak what
it was so it was an
honor for me um to be a part of this
ceremony
and even though chadwick didn't win
he's still number one in your heart
correct he's
number one in my heart
when you weren't on the stage where did
you go and what did you do when you
weren't on the stage because it was a
smaller venue a smaller space
they would jock us in and out in and out
so actually maybe about
four you know four uh
commercial breaks or so before before i
presented i was
in i was in the audience as an audience
member
but before that i was backstage i was
either in
probably the main union station hallway
which is now
where i am now which we call our green
room
but there are so many different areas to
be in there's a lovely
outdoor area uh where they
oh just drape the trees and flowers and
lights it's really beautiful and there's
the end door here with the art deco
of the union snakes there's also another
south courtyard you can get lost around
here
that there's sort of an indoor
backspace where you just before you
go on and that's where hallie and i hung
out
we got to catch up so that was wonderful
um
so it was really beautiful it was it was
lovely i i was really
interested to come here yes via the of
course during this time
during this time of kobe the academy
award to see
what it looks like and uh it was very
intimate
it's very intimate i i wonder if there's
some way we can retain
the best of it yeah
okay two two last things before i let
you go number one
um the message of tonight and so many of
the messages we heard were about
diversity inclusion in hollywood moving
forward despite this pandemic not
letting this
stop us and did you feel that tonight
absolutely especially if you looked
around at
the different faces uh individuals
whether
you know walking or in wheelchairs
or what i mean or language
would be various would know it it was
just very resilient um it was just a lot
of
a lot of love and a lot of i felt just
appreciation for humanity
and our differences didn't make a
difference
okay and here's the other thing where do
you go tonight because listen oscar
night is a big party night we know in
hollywood
what do you do tonight you you're in
oh you know all the parties um
well we just stay here we go to the
north to the north portico
or the south portico
you know finally i thought we would you
know
you know do your work get your statue
and go home
that's a big part of it but people are
sort of
mingling around a little bit hanging
around a little bit because
at the end of such a an awesome day at
the end of
hollywood's christmas christmas morning
you know we uh we want to celebrate each
other and we want to sort of relax you
know it's always a
a big deal getting ready but this is you
know you know we sort of hold
together a lot of adrenaline now the
adrenaline just had
and we just saw going
oh by the way did you ever think you
would see glenn
close do the butt never
come over and i guess i love that
that's a highlight for the ages